Perpetual motion machines have held a real fascination for inventors...
...for the last several hundred, if not thousand years.
The idea of extracting free energy somehow is a very, very lucrative...
...and seductive one.
Now, to do that, you have to play with the laws of thermodynamics.
Everybody knows the laws of thermodynamics, right?
You can't win.
You can't break even.
You can't get out of the game, right?
So, that said, perpetual motion machines try to defy that...
...through clever systems, using magnets, and waterfalls,...
...and siphons, and gravity, and counterweights.
They purport to extract free energy from the universe somehow.
The patent office of the United States government was so besieged...
...by applications for these things that finally they said,...
..."no more, stop bothering us unless you can bring us a working model...
...that you can park out in our outer office...
...where it will run for one year, with no intervention."
And since then, applications have been way down.